[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
en 20 ans l'Internet s'est éloigné de la
promesse initiale d'un espace ouvert si
bien que la question de la régulation du
numérique est devenue un sujet central
des politiques publiques
mercredi 5 juillet 2023 les sénateurs
ont adopté à l'unanimité un projet de
loi visant à sécuriser les risques liés
aux usages quotidiens d'Internet pour
les individus et les entreprises
il prévoit par exemple la mise en place
d'un filtre national de cybersécurité
afin d'alerter les internautes lorsqu'un
site présente un risque avéré d'arnaque
ou d'escroquerie sur de nombreux sujets
le Sénat est allé plus loin que le texte
initial
c'est notamment le cas en matière de
lutte contre les effets toxiques de la
pornographie sur internet
ainsi les personnes liées par contrat à
un éditeur de contenu pornographiques
pourront obtenir des hébergeurs le
retrait de contenu diffusés en violation
des modalités convenues le Sénat a
également permis aux régulateur de
bloquer le téléchargement des
applications qui ne respectent pas le
contrôle légal des limites d'âge dans le
domaine de la lutte contre les
comportements associés sur internet le
Sénat a complété la liste des délits
pour lesquels la peine complémentaire de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux sera
encouru notamment pour des menaces à
l'encontre des dépositaires d'une
fonction publique il a également créé un
délit d'outrage en ligne qui pourra
faire l'objet d'une sanction immédiate
par le biais d'une amende forfaitaire
délictuelle
enfin le Sénat obtenu l'engagement du
gouvernement de lancer rapidement un
travail conjoint pour traiter la
question de la lutte contre la
propagation via les réseaux sociaux de
contenus à plan manifestement à la
violence dans des contextes d'émeutes ou
d'autres atteintes graves à l'ordre
public le texte est désormais transmis à
l'Assemblée nationale
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]